we are now raising funds to build houses
for those who have been homeless due to
natural disasters in Afghanistan Syria
and Pakistan please donate whatever you
can may Allah build you guys at home for
helping and enabling them to have a
house
outfit you got
it what's your name
let me ask you a question
what would you say is your purpose in
life why are we here where are we going
have you ever wondered who has created
me who's made my eyes what color is your
eyes
blue who's made your eyes blue
I don't know what do you think would you
say okay let me ask you a question would
you say you're happy yeah what about you
yeah 12 out of ten ten nine oh okay
that's good what do all your happiness
do
um
nothing really are you always in a state
of mind or does it fluctuating
fluctuates naturally okay good so
do you have do you believe in higher
power like a Creator ah no okay
if you don't mind me assuming are you
gay yes okay would you say that has a
direct connection with you not having a
relationship with God like do you feel
like you've been felt to be shunned and
I'm is that making no okay because
sometimes I speak like I have friends
who are like not friends about people
that I know who have these Tendencies as
well or who are gay and sometimes they
feel as if God hates them and he doesn't
like them and we say look I'm a Muslim
and of course in our religion it's a sin
but we don't look at you and be like oh
he is doomed to hell we can't see that
I'm trying to say like I'm a Muslim
there could be a really good Muslim who
dies we can't come and say he's going
Paradise neither I can look at you and
be like oh he's definitely going hell
this is arrogance so one of the things
Islam came to deal with is arrogant
individuals walking around proud as if
here I'm righteous do you get it
righteous then die so the attitude is
that please like you as a gay man
do not feel as if we as religious people
look down on you or we feel any less
just know that you can have that
relationship with God
so keep that in mind I just wanted to
tell you because sometimes I speak
there's a perception that we you know
feel weird or no I'm looking to speak to
more gay people but the Quran is there
have you read it before no
no can I give you a copy no thank you
that's fine thank you for your time
thank you I really appreciate it it's a
pleasure you're once again take care of
yourself thank you take care what's your
name today hey
what's your name
hoodie Woody how you doing Woody my name
is Ali how's life
by the way I have pink shirts as well I
think it looks good on me thank you some
might differ my wife says it looks good
but I think I appreciate it thank you it
looks good on you as well okay I'm a
Muslim okay and I know I'm assuming you
are please forgive me you okay yeah
that's fine a lot of people have this
misconception that as Muslims we
disregard dislike that's not the case we
believe that God Almighty has created
everybody and we all tested in different
ways so my religion doesn't make me
despise you're looking in a certain way
it just says that different people are
created in different ways and also that
we all have tests I have a test you have
a test but the ultimate test is what for
us to have a relationship with God
Almighty and a lot of people who have
who are gay who act on the homosexuality
or not they think that God hates them
God doesn't hate them it's just a test
yes the action we believe is sinful but
I just wanted you to know that I don't
look at you in that manner so because a
lot of people have this misconception
have you read the Quran before no
can I give you one
if you want to be an honor if I can give
you one for free if can you take it in
there I don't know okay let me give you
one for free yeah so just if you ever
get the chance please do read it you
know yes it's going to be a Muslim in
two minutes give me a second I'm joking
so yeah look if you have any questions
you have any misconceptions about Islam
do you have any no nothing I don't think
do you know anything about Islam uh yeah
I did uh did a lot on it for mine okay
we believe God is one and he's sent
prophet and he sent guidance for us
ultimate happiness I wasn't on Muslim 10
years ago I came to Islam and believe me
I used to go partying clubbing Etc but
it came a moment of my life where I was
like is this all it is there a greater
purpose so then I just ventured out and
looked at different religions and I
became Muslim but that's it I don't hold
you I know you're going to a party it
was a pleasure Woody I'm so sorry thank
you very much take care thank you much I
think look it's very important guys that
we convey this message you know why
because sometimes I speak to a lot of
people who are who have these Tendencies
and they feel as if they are doomed they
are finished they have no trains chance
they're gonna go hell that's not the
case in our religion yes it's a sin yes
we hate the sin and in certain instances
we can't hate The Sinner as well but the
doors of repentance is open for
everybody you cannot look at somebody
and feel as if you are more righteous
than them it can be that this man
becomes a Muslim and becomes better than
you so we need a very very be very
careful with our attitude and be like oh
let me see that guy like sometimes I'm
here trying to speak to people I'm
speaking to let's see a trans and some
people can't y'all why are you speaking
to him why should I not speak to him
didn't Islam come for him did it just
come for the righteous people is the
message just for the pious so please
guys inshallah our aim is to inshallah
convey that message and win their hearts
over inshallah the prophet Muhammad
sallam did when he would go to war he
would if he if he had Camus he would
give camels to the battle in Arabs why
to win their hearts towards Islam
assalamualaikum